CURRENY T FIRST WILD CARD
TEAM IN THE WESTERN CONFERENCE
THAT CAN VILLE HUSSO
MA GREAT STOP ON HIM.
BACK AT THE POINT, HOLDEN A
>> Jam: A GRADE "A "LOOK FOR
LOOKING FOR
OPTION BACK TOO
PIETRA
HE'S GETTING MOST OF THE
DEFEE START. LOOSE
PUCK.
D HERE'S KRUG WITH GOINGRO
THE STICK
WITH ANOTH GOOD OPPORTUNITY IN
TIGHT, MATT MURRAY IN GOOD
POSITI TARASENKO LOOKING
FOR HIS 17th GOAL O THE
SKATE, NICK PAUL TRIES TO B ACRO
BORTUZ.
KNOCKED DOWN BY BUCHNEVICH,OSH
BE THE TRIGGER MAN IN T T IT UPS
HERE KRUG WITH IT.
BRETT HSECOND.
LIUG, TO FAULK,
JUST IN, HOLDDOWN, MOVING THE
PUCK AROUND, THE SUPPORT,
TAKEN BY BORTUZZO.
GAMBT, AND A REDIRECT INNBUT WH
DEFENS
WAS TAKEN OFF THE PUCK. IN AND
GAUD BACK TOASHEV,
BA TOWARDS THE GOAL, MURRAY
MAK .
>> G SO ARE THE REST OF
>> R: OTTAWA
TARAG TO PIVOT AND TAKE IT TO L
SIX GAM  FOR A
FREEBI
MAKES THE P THAT
BA IN  IS EMPTY.
FREEE INTEREST.
TARAO TRIES TO COME OUT AND
TRY